today we're talking about how to tell if
an optional parameter has been passed in
this first case is the lucky case
because we don't have to
in this case x is either passed in or it
gets the value 42
but it's not always possible to put the
value of your default argument in the
function definition up here
for instance in this case the default
argument that we want
is the length of an array we can't know
that length when we define the function
so we have to compute it dynamically
another reason not to put a default
value up here is if the default value is
mutable like a dictionary
default values are defined at the time
that the function is defined
not when the function is called so if
you had
a default mutable argument like a
dictionary then that dictionary would be
shared amongst
all calls to the function doing this is
a very common source of bugs
so you might be tempted to do the
following set the default value to none
and then use a boolean expression to
tell whether or not none was passed in
this isn't always wrong but i do think
it's a bad habit
what if zero or the empty dictionary
were valid parameters
this code would throw out those
parameters and replace them with the
defaults
what i recommend doing is the following
again keep none as your default argument
and then set x to be either itself if
it's not none or otherwise compute the
default
this explicit check to see whether x is
none allows us to pass in zero if we
need to
you can also do it this way explicitly
checking if the parameter is none
and setting the default if it is i
prefer
always using this explicit check against
none because it's one less thing that i
have to think about
i don't need to worry about whether 0 or
an empty object might be a valid
parameter
however there is one exceedingly rare
case
where this still isn't enough what if i
actually want to distinguish between the
cases when a user passes in
none versus when they don't pass in
anything
if you are writing a function this way i
really encourage you to take a look at
your function and think about it
do you really need to distinguish those
cases is there any way you can avoid it
most of the time i think you can avoid
it but especially for
code that writes other code or highly
generic code
sometimes it just can't be avoided
for those cases we'll use something
called a sentinel
a sentinel is an object whose sole
purpose is to
check whether or not something is or
isn't the sentinel value
in many cases it's okay to use the
python built-in none as a sentinel
value that's what we did in the previous
example but
if we want to distinguish none then we
have to make our own sentinel
once again we just set the sentinel to
be the default value
and then check explicitly using the is
operator whether or not the past and
argument is the sentinel
now we can easily distinguish whether we
have the sentinel value or none
here we have two example uses of the
sentinel pattern
in the python standard library on the
left we see its use in the data classes
library
and on the right we see its use in the
funk tools library
however the sentinel pattern will get
you into trouble if you want to type
check your code
you can see here that mypi is giving me
an error correctly
telling me that missing isn't the right
type
the way that the standard library gets
around this is by using the overload
decorator
from the typing library get rid of the
type annotations in your actual
implementation of the function then
just before the implementation of the
function you need to write a separate
overload for every possible combination
of types that could be passed into the
function
at runtime this implementation is the
only one that actually gets called and
so it must handle all the possible type
combinations that could be passed in
the overload decorator's purpose is more
to help static type checkers like my pie
you can see now that the program passes
my pi's type check
that's all i have this time thanks for
watching don't forget to like comment
and subscribe